mais si vous glissez bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors première question quelle influence
peut aujourd'hui avoir le quad
alors c'est ça qui va être intéressant à
voir puisque on est passé d'un système
était très bilatérales et qu'était le
mode de fonctionnement du président
américain précédent un retour à la
diplomatie beaucoup plus classique qui
est la marque de des démocrates
américains en particulier qui consiste à
utiliser des alliances des groupements
puisque très clairement c'est quand même
la chine qui est visé par la cette
réunion le du quad
alors le quad a été créée en 2007
aujourd'hui dans quel contexte
géopolitique se réunissent ses
dirigeants alors par rapport à 2005 il y
avait quelque chose qui a changé
largement c'est la perception de la
menace chinoise par l'australie et par
mende
en 2007 c'était le japon qui était qui
était le plus visé avec les bagarres
autour des îles qui sont contestées
entre le japon et la chine alors que
l'inde et l'australie avaient une
position relativement souple visa mine
de la chine les incidents de frontière
ado chinois et les menaces de la chine
envers l'australie ont largement changé
la donne ces derniers temps alors
contrer la menace chinoise on sait que
les quatre puissances du quad ont des
visions très différentes dans leurs
relations avec pékin dans leur vision
géopolitique également de la région indo
pacifique à votre avis quelle sera la
feuille de route de ce groupe de
dialogue informel la feuille de route ça
c'est quelque chose justement c'est le
défaut de ces diplomatie très classique
c'est que ces feuilles de route il ya
des déclarations qui seront sans nombre
de déclarations sur la liberté de
circulation sur le respect des
réglementations internationales sur le
respect de la loi de la mer ce seront
des déclarations on se retrouve un petit
peu à l'époque obama où il ya eu
beaucoup de déclarations des états unis
et leur pivot vers vers la chine a le
pacifique un qui n'ont pas été suivies
d'effet
donc pas il n a l'air d'être repoussé
par une groupe à l'intérieur de son
propre pays et beaucoup de cultures
vis-à-vis de la chine
est-ce qu'on va dépasser dépasser le
système de déclaration est passé à
quelque chose de plus dur la liane aussi
aurait sans doute en 8a c'est quelque
chose de plus dur à l'heure actuelle et
la vienne
et quoi de c'est un petit peu le nez
petit et le grand frère justement pour
en venir à l'administration by dunn est
ce que vous pensez qu'il va donner un
ton différent par rapport à
l'administration trump on qui qui était
délibérément antichinois alors un
discours de ben ali
c'est à peu près la seule chose sur
lequel il ya eu un peu de changements si
vous voulez au niveau de la campagne
électorale le discours de bail dunhill
ami de la chine est exactement aussi dur
que le discours des autres oeuvres de
trump le discours de trump cette édition
d'un homme avec une administration qui
suivrait mais qui suivait alors que le
discours de bayonne c'est plutôt dispose
d'une administration qui pousse un homme
le premier ministre
le premier ministre australien a déclaré
qu'il était très important aujourd'hui
de collaborer coopérer ensemble pour
justement contrer cette menace que
représente aujourd'hui la chine
alors effectivement une coopération
ça serait une solution mais là aussi on
va avoir des discours sur la coopération
est ce qu'on aura un élu ali télé
réalité ça voudrait dire quelque chose
de vraiment visible sur le plan
militaire sur le plan des des sanctions
éventuelles sur le port de la présence
physique en mer de chine du sud tout
particulièrement mais aussi un peu
partout dans la zone et des liens plus
directs et plus visible avec l'agréable
est-ce que là la réponse doit être pas
seulement sécuritaire politique mais
aussi économique commerciale alors il
est bien évident que le ce et réponses
commerciales en particulier et ce très
importante c'est ça devient difficile à
l'heure actuelle trop l'inde 1 qui a de
plus en plus de liens économiques avec
la chine alors que le japon est là et
l'australie peuvent se permettre un
petit peu plus de puissance
jean vincent brisset merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'iris et spécialiste de la chine